[Music]
everybody Madol Brian's back and that
great he had that's exciting news you
had two kids and then a six week hiatus
to take excuse me pardon me six weeks
count'em six six weeks we're all ready
boys and we're already calling those two
weeks the show's golden era this is
unbelievable
firing on all cylinders well my daughter
Nev was born and one day off well that's
different you're broken inside you can
laugh at that he knows so I had an
option to stay out longer sure you could
oh yeah they kept saying you can and I
was like I gotta get back there I gotta
get out I said I gotta get me laughs I
got it I gotta pay attention to the real
kids
what's it thank you
he had the bracket I think I think you
called me and said it's a boy
I think I was here I was there was you
know I'm not gonna can you know who else
is gonna talk to Alf if not me those
were different times and so please if
you said Beckett three times just trying
to remember who that was
Beckett Beckett Beckett Beckett oh right
that kid oh man he's gonna try and get
my money like a CMOS but I've got it
buried where he'll never find it I also
hear that Matt's already got the kids in
private school like in a boarding school
yeah yeah they've been sent off to
military academy they're each wearing a
military medal that's no big it's their
whole body
it's a Montessori sleepaway school how
dare you take care you take time away
from this show for those for your
precious life
I asked you to be here he does things
like that all the time
it's a tatis he plays the good guy yeah
and you're supposed to go no no no yes
see the good guys like a good Japanese
host refuses nine times right right no I
couldn't I couldn't you're supposed to
be my insist anyway
important thing is I'm glad the children
are here they're healthy and you they no
longer need you you'll be here now don't
you think my dad I never saw my dad in
the 70s or the 80s right that worked out
great
what are you talking about I'm rich
possibly wrong with the way I was raised
I got it all and my entire family ah
we're leaking oil all over the place I
remember the first time you and it was
the night of the first show in 93 you
came into my what did you do to him it's
an icebreaker yeah no but now she
doesn't know who a lot of people are Oh
but every time I see her she'll be like
how's that Andy oh I like nice yeah she
always says that she means Andy Devine
sure sure
well that's fine with me she means Andy
Summers from the police
[Music]
you